okay
yeah yeah yeah I mean I just it's not
right not right
ready to go until thank you so much we
really appreciate it problem thank you
I think I'll get on the lawrence
O'Donnell show you got the backstage
pass enough to kick me out they say no I
mean I think a big news event would be
like tsunami kind of thing that would be
like you can't not talk about it the
whole time sure this is big this is
bigger for MSNBC it's nice to be
properly lit I must say Oh television
has a strange power especially in
American culture it lends credibility
instant credibility to people that
sometimes don't want absolutely
hello everyone I'm here in the studio
where I'll be be forming hello everyone
I'm here in the studio well we're hello
everyone I'm here in the studio where
I'll be be you where I will be recording
hello everyone I'm here in the studio
where I will be recording my segment on
the last word this is a little studio
that they got us in right here I got
this earpiece in my ear I can hear the
host Melissa harris-perry talking right
now that's the camera that will be
filming us and this is the little TVs
where I can see myself which I have
asked them to turn off because as I said
in my first vlog I cannot not look at
myself so we're waiting right now
listening to Melissa do the show but
she's gonna talk - hi Evan how are you
good how are you Melissa oh we were
absolutely blown away by your video can
I tell you we have been emailing it to
one another and playing it over and over
again what inspired you to make it well
I was watching last night when Lawrence
said you know it was the simplicity of
the idea and I I completely agree with
that but I think it's that plus the fact
that it's something that you you don't
think of you know and that's what struck
me when I originally heard him announce
it a year ago on the show is that
something you never think of and so it
sort of hits you in that that feel bad
organ whatever that is and you you get
that reflexive feeling like he said last
night to donate so it was uploaded five
days ago and you've gotten more than
200,000 hits what is what have been the
reaction you've been getting from people
online who've seen it the reaction has
been I use the word aggressively
generous it is the the comments just on
the video have been like donated they
just say donate or they say you know I
just took a kid off the floor in Malawi
and to know that you could possibly kind
of do make that effect in the world by
making a video is it's truly incredible
now speaking of that I mean it's a small
range the small thing in desks it's a
small thing to make a video so so what
is your ultimate goal though so you have
this small thing but then you have a
video that crescendos to winning the
Nobel Prize what's your question know
here what what would you like this video
to do what
like it to do is it was a it was a video
for the project for awesome which is a
YouTube charity event that happens every
year where people make videos on a
charity of their choice they submit them
the community watches them it's hosted
by John and Hank green of the
vlogbrothers we just have a lot of
people at their disposal online and we
all donate it to the project for awesome
I think it raised about seventy one
thousand dollars and what we're waiting
for now is the top voted charities are
going to get some of that money they're
going to be divvied up based on what the
votes are and the ultimate goal for this
is to get some more money for the kind
fund because we could actually make a
huge difference getting getting
classrooms you know not just kids but
classrooms off the floor well even the
video is indeed awesome and I thank you
I have absolutely no authority to do so
I gotta tell you that's look good enough
video that I don't know maybe somebody
ought to be talking to you here at MSNBC
line up that was a great video thank you
very much I appreciate it
thanks Evan Lawrence the entire last
word team all of us thank you for your
help now you can find thank you very
much okay the spot is over I'm sweating
at the armpits you can't see because I'm
wearing two shirts let's let's get
we just finished filming at Pacific
television studios did the segment I
think it went great I was really nervous
it went by so fast she was really nice
extremely you know
gracious and I just tried to gracious
back and I hope we watch it tonight it
looks good and I and you can't see the
sweat from under my arms thank you very
much for tuning in
back to the limo